We're asked to subtract.
And we have the
problem 68 minus 42.
And what I want
to do here is one,
just show you how I
would do this problem,
and then talk a little bit
about why it actually works.
So if I have 68 minus
42, one way to do it--
and this is probably
the most typical way--
is to write the number you're
subtracting from on top,
and write the number that you're
subtracting from that number
below that.
So we're going to
have 68 minus 42.
And the thing you really
want to make sure you do
is that you want to align
it according to place.
So the 2 is below the 8.
They're both in the ones place.
And the 4 is below the 6.
They're both in the tens place.
And later in this video,
it should be clear--
or I'll hopefully
make it clear--
why that's a good thing to do.
So then we go to the ones
place, and we see an 8.
And from that, we're
going to subtract a 2.
So 8 minus 2 is 6.
I'll write that over here.
Let me write that over here.
8 minus 2 is 6.
8 minus 2 is equal to 6.
And then we go to
the tens place.
We have 6 minus 4.
And since they're
[? in ?] tens place,
this is really 60 minus 40.
But 6 minus 4 is 2.
6 minus 4 is equal to 2.
And since these are
in the tens place,
this is really saying 60
minus 40 is equal to 20.
And I'll make that a little
bit clearer in a second.
So we're actually done here.
68 minus 42 is equal to 26.
And you can check
that for yourself.
If you add 26 plus
42, you should get 68.
Or if you subtract 26 from
68, you should get 42.
So I encourage you do that in
your own time after this video.
Verify that 42 plus
26 is equal to 68.
And also verify what 68
minus 26 is equal to.
And you should see
that it is equal to 42.
So these are two things for
you to check on your own.
Now, the last thing I
want to do in this video
is just to explain in
a little bit more depth
why this actually works.
And at least in my mind,
I like to visualize 68.
You won't have to
write it out like this,
but it's one way to
make sure you really
understand what's going on here.
68 is the same thing as
60 plus 8, or 60 and 8.
And from that, we're
subtracting 42.
But 42 is the same
thing as 40 plus 2.
So we're subtracting 40,
and we're subtracting 2.
We're subtracting 42.
We're subtracting 40 and 2.
And so you could view this as
really two separate problems.
In the ones place,
you have an 8 minus 2.
And that's is exactly
what we did over here.
You have a 6.
And then in the tens place,
you have a 60 minus 40,
which is 20.
So you end up with 20 plus 6.
And you know that that's
the same exact thing as 26.